Jean-Yves Morel aurait-il menti pour les
gendarmes les raisons de le soupçonner
sont décidément nombreuses seulement ils
ne dispose d'aucune preuve tangible
alors après 36 heures de garde à vue la
cellule d'enquête se voit obligée de
relâcher Jean-Yves Morel l'affaire
aurait pu en rester là mais va bientôt
connaître un incroyable rebondissement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes le 5 avril 1996 en
Haute-Normandie dans la région de Rouen
dans le village de la fresnaise vers 13h
une voiture s'arrête rue Georges Fleury
et de jeunes femmes ont des cendres
[Musique]
elle se ressemblent un peu normale elles
sont seules
il y a Nadine Morel 28 ans et Marylène
17 ans
tous les vendredis elle déjeune ensemble
chez Nadine qui vit dans ce petit
pavillon
les deux femmes s'entendent bien et
elles ont leurs habitudes
mais pendant le repas Nadine s'aperçoit
que sa soeur cadette à quelque chose à
lui demander
des jeunes tranquillement
Marylène paraît soucieuse paraît un
petit peu angoissé et au fil de la
conversation lors du repas sa sœur
s'aperçoit que
Marylène a envie de sortir avec son
petit ami le lendemain que ses parents
ne sont pas au courant et elle voudrait
bien que sa sœur réussir dalibi pour
cette sortie seulement Nadine refuse de
mentir à ses parents d'autant qu'elle
trouve sa soeur trop jeune pour
découcher
sa soeur n'est pas d'accord parce que
c'est une Marylène est une jeune fille
qui n'a pas l'habitude de sortir qui
vient un petit peu dans le cocon
familial dans les jupes de ses parents
Jean et Ginette Rousset
tout semble en rester là
et ce petit désaccord n'est plus évoqué
jusqu'à la fin du repas
en début d'après-midi Nadine repart au
travail comme à son habitude et comme
tous les vendredis après-midi Marylène
va faire quelques tâches ménagères pour
soulager sa sœur au domicile de la
fenêtre
[Musique]
en fin de journée dans le laboratoire
d'analyses où elle est réceptionniste
Nadine va recevoir un appel inattendu
[Musique]
à l'autre bout du fil c'est son mari
Jean-Yves Morel et il a une étrange
nouvelle à lui annoncer
Jean-Yves Moret appelle sa femme Nadine
il est 16h30 il vient de rentrer du
travail et il dit pouvoir trouver un mot
de la main de sa belle-sœur
je pars ne vous occupez pas de moi on se
reverra bientôt mais pas avant mardi
[Musique]
ce petit mot énigmatique surprend Nadine
il était convenu que Marylène dorme chez
elle ce vendredi soir alors pourquoi
est-elle partie cela a-t-il un rapport
avec leur désaccord du déjeuner
mais au téléphone Jean-Yves ne s'arrête
pas là
il lui dit aussi qu'il manque de 100
francs qu'ils avaient laissé à la maison
Nadine ne comprend pas tout cela ne
ressemble pas à Marylène
la jeune femme rentre chez elle espérant
que sa sœur va réapparaître
mais à 20h30 Marylène n'est toujours pas
revenue
Nadine et son mari Jean-Yves décident
d'aller alerter les parents Denis et
Ginette Rousset qui vivent dans un
village très proche
donc Jean-Yves Morel et Nadine Morel
décide le soir de se rendre au domicile
des parents Rousset Denis et son épouse
ils informent donc que Marylène a quitté
la maison en laissant ce mot toute la
famille est très inquiète c'est pas dans
les habitudes de Marylène d'agir ainsi
cependant d'accoman accord il décide
tous d'attendre effectivement mardi le
retour de Marylène mais contrairement à
ce qui est écrit sur le mot Marylène ne
reviendra pas ni mardi ni plus tard
mardi 9 avril 1996 la famille de
Marylène décide de signaler sa
disparition à la gendarmerie cela fait
maintenant 5 jours qu'elle n'a donné
aucune nouvelle Denis Rousset arrive
avec Nadine sa fille à la gendarmerie de
Caudebec-en-Caux pour signaler la
disparition de Marylène ils ont pris
avec eux le mot que leur fille avait
laissé monsieur Rousset confirme au
gendarmes de Caudebec c'est l'écriture
de sa fille une enquête est ouverte mais
bien sûr on s'oriente assez rapidement
vers une fugue de la jeune fille il faut
dire que pour les gendarmes tout
corrobore la thèse d'une fugue Marylène
a écrit un mot qui évoque clairement un
départ volontaire et elle a pris 200
francs chez Nadine sans doute pour
financer son départ et le petit
désaccord qu'elle a eu à midi avec sa
sœur à certainement déclenché son geste
alors les gendarmes se cantonnent à une
enquête de routine mais pour la famille
cela ne suffit pas
l'hypothèse de la fugue n'est pas du
tout n'est pas du tout probante pour la
famille Rousset tout simplement parce
que Marylène Rousset est une jeune femme
est une jeune fille calme qui a quelques
amis mais qui ne sort pas qui rentrent
systématiquement chez elle elle n'a
jamais fugué par le passé et elle n'a
jamais émis l'idée de de quitter le
domicile familial
décidé à retrouver Marylène
effrayer à l'idée qu'il lui soit arrivé
quelque chose de grave sa famille décide
d'agir
on met des espèces d'avis de recherche
on fait des démarches pour essayer
d'avoir des informations de qui aura vu
et pourra donner des renseignements
partout des affiches sont placardées
toute la famille s'active ses parents sa
soeur Nadine et son beau-frère Jean-Yves
tout le monde cherche marielène et dans
les semaines qui suivent quelques
témoins vont se manifester parfois les
vues en Normandie dans un village
éloigné d'autres personnes la voient en
Moselle où elles seraient partie avec
quelqu'un de plus âgé qu'elle toutes les
pistes sont exploitées mais ce sont des
rumeurs parce que quand les
vérifications sont faites n'importe rien
il y a rien de concret qui permet
d'accréditer effectivement la présence
de Marlène quelque part des pistes bien
faibles Marylène reste introuvable mais
ses proches ne baisse pas pour autant
les bras et c'est le mari de Nadine
Jean-Yves Morel qui se montre le plus
volontaire Jean-Yves Morel se sent
responsable de la disparition de
Marylène Rousset sa belle-sœur parce que
elle a disparu depuis son domicile il
est quand même celui qui a priori et le
dernier à être arrivé dans cette maison
qu'elle venait de quitter et en tout cas
le premier avoir trouvé le mot de sa
belle-sœur
c'est peut-être aussi lui qui a le plus
haut niveau de d'études qui est le plus
qualifié qui qui s'exprime le mieux qui
a une vision un peu plus abstraite aussi
des choses sans doute et donc c'est il
est le meneur et il va aider toute sa
belle-famille entreprendre ses
recherches donc sans cesse il a ce rôle
aussi bien auprès des parents de
Marylène que de sa femme de rassurer
l'entourage familial en disant on va
continuer à chercher on va la retrouver
elle est vivante c'est sûr j'en suis
certain et puis ce que les affichettes
n'ont pas suffi Jean-Yves a une nouvelle
idée ils veulent lancer un avis de
recherche mais cette fois dans une
émission de télévision qui fait beaucoup
de bruit à l'époque
perdu de vue
c'est Jean-Yves Morel qui va réussir à
convaincre les parents de Marylène
Rousset donc Jean et Ginette Rousset de
se rendre à cette émission c'est c'est
il a d'autant plus il a dû d'autant plus
être convaincant que les parents de
Marylène Rousset sont vraiment des
Normands pure souches des taiseux pas
des gens qui vont s'exposer facilement
dans une émission télé sur un plateau
télé donc il faut vraiment les
convaincre et c'est ce que Jean-Yves
Morel va s'employer à faire et qu'il va
réussir à faire donc on le sent très
motivé dans la recherche de Marylène
Rousset on est vraiment inquiet pour
pour Marylène on aimerait avoir de ses
nouvelles nous avez monsieur je pense
beaucoup réfléchi à tout ça aussi c'est
Denis Rousset son père qui se fait le
porte-parole de l'inquiétude familiale
tellement parce que vous savez nous
l'idée c'est que elle devait revenir le
mardi
depuis il en a toujours rien oui mais je
veux dire bon quand il y a peut-être
quelques conflits dans une famille où il
y a des règles de vie familiale je sais
pas
aucun problème avec ma fille
mais ni pendant l'émission ni le
lendemain on ne recueillera de nouvelles
informations sur Marylène au fil des
semaines qui se transforment en moi
l'inquiétude devient angoisse et l'on
aurait peut-être jamais su ce que
marielène était devenu si une deuxième
disparition n'était intervenue dans la
région quelques mois plus tard
2 juillet 1997 on signale à la
gendarmerie de Saint-Romain de colbeau
dans la région de Rouen la disparition
d'une jeune fille de 23 ans Elisabeth
Griffin
la dernière fois qu'on l'a vu c'était 9
jours plus tôt elisabeth a passé le week
end dans la maison de son père
avant de reprendre la route pour
rejoindre son appartement d'étudiante à
Rouen
[Musique]
ils habitent Griffin est une étudiante
qui travaille beaucoup elle prépare ses
examens pour sa troisième année de
chimie qu'elle suit à l'Université de
Rouen
et là une dernière fois sa sœur
Géraldine au téléphone donc elle est
tout semble bien aller pour Elisabeth
Wifi qui est alors en pleine révision
seulement après ce coup de téléphone
plus personne ne réussira à joindre
Elisabeth
[Musique]
son petit ami Thomas Deschamps essaie de
l'appeler à plusieurs reprises dès le
lendemain
mais le téléphone sonne dans le vide
pas la joindre
ça m'étonne un peu quand même
on comprend pas ce qui se passe je
comprends pas ce qui se passe que
pourquoi elle n'est pas là je sais pas
ce qu'elle boude je sais pas du tout
ce matin là la jeune femme ne se
présente pas non plus au rendez-vous
qu'elle avait fixé avec ses camarades de
l'université elle devait pourtant
recevoir des résultats d'examens qui lui
tenaient à cœur
[Musique]
les jours passent
et l'inquiétude grandit
ça devient inquiétant oui effectivement
nous on commence à mettre des affiches
et tout ça
il y en a eu plusieurs qui tournent sur
Le Havre d'affiche en avril recherche
tout simplement c'est ce qui peut être
proche de Rouen et ce qui peut être
proche du Havre ce qui peut tout
simplement être en France est-ce que je
sais pas
elle n'est pas là elle n'est pas là
9 jours après la disparition d'Elizabeth
toutes les hypothèses sont envisagées
par les gendarmes
suicide disparition volontaire
enlèvement une enquête est ouverte et
l'on va rapidement comprendre que c'est
bien d'une affaire criminelle dont il
sèche
[Musique]
le 3 juillet 1990 le lendemain du
signalement de la disparition
d'Elisabeth sa voiture est retrouvée à
Lillebonne une petite ville située à 60
km de Rouen
pas de traces de la jeune femme mais ses
effets personnels sont toujours à
l'intérieur du véhicule ce véhicule est
découvert abandonné depuis quelques
jours avec tous ses papiers à
l'intérieur véhicules non non fermé avec
le sac d'Elisabeth sur le siège passager
avant
[Musique]
dans ce sac il ne manque absolument rien
tous ces papiers sont présents carte
d'identité carte bancaire carnets de
chèques mais ce qui va le plus intriguer
les enquêteurs dans ce sac c'est un
petit bout de papier qui porte quelques
mots manuscrits
[Musique]
Fred Deezer le 24
le 24 ce pourrait être le mardi 24 juin
jour de la disparition d'Elizabeth
la jeune femme avait-elle un rendez-vous
ce jour-là avec un certain Fred il se
trouve qu'il y a bien un Fred ou plutôt
une Frédéric dans l'entourage
d'Elizabeth une amie de son petit copain
Thomas Deschamps immédiatement les
gendarmes envisagent une rivalité entre
les deux jeunes femmes une rivalité qui
aurait pu mal tourner de là s'ouvre de
nouvelles investigations puisque en
extrapolant un peu on pouvait imaginer
qu'elle soit à l'origine de la
disparition d'Elizabeth en complicité
éventuelle avec des gens d'ailleurs
frédéric est interrogé mais rapidement
mis hors de cause
en revanche le petit ami d'Elizabeth
Thomas a un comportement lui pour le
moins étrange de la part d'un jeune
homme dont la fiancée a disparu un
détail nous a paru aussi un petit peu
surprenant c'est que il était parti très
peu de temps après la disparition des
diabète pour encadrer une colonie de
vacances en Espagne
pour un quelqu'un qui était
présenté comme son amoureux du moment on
a trouvé ça un petit peu léger quoi ce
qui a renforcé nos doutes à son égard ce
qu'ils a surpris c'est que je sois pas
là cet été en fait c'est ce qui s'est
passé j'étais en Espagne réfugiée
protégé pas pas tous les jours devant
tous les jours devant les affiches pas
tous les jours à ne pas avoir de
nouvelles d'Elizabeth
pour aller jusqu'au bout de leur
soupçons les gendarmes place Thomas des
champs en garde à vue
un peu gênante on peut se poser des
questions parce que s'ils en arrivent à
mettre un la vue c'est qu'ils ont quand
même des idées moi je
j'aimerais bien savoir les pistes qui
l'ont amené parce que moi j'ai rien à me
reprocher donc je suis un peu inquiet
quand même mais après avoir vérifié son
emploi du temps les gendarmes sont bien
obligés d'admettre que Thomas est
innocent
le jeune homme est aussitôt libéré
[Musique]
les enquêteurs s'orientent alors vers
une autre piste dans les relevés
téléphoniques d'Elizabeth Griffin ils
ont découvert un coup de téléphone
suspect qu'elle a reçu le matin même de
sa disparition on sait qu'il y a un
appel téléphonique est arrivé à son
domicile à 7h58 n'appelle téléphonique
d'une minute et quelques secondes qui
émane d'une cabine téléphonique de la
remuer une commune de La Remuée qui pas
très loin du lieu d'amandon de véhicule
de Lillebonne cette cabine téléphonique
la voici l'auteur du coup de fil
pourrait-il être un éventuel kidnappeur
les gendarmes vont mener l'enquête dans
le voisinage mais là encore en pure
perte
même fait des surveillances physiques
aux horaires correspondants de cette
cabine malheureusement sans succès
puisque nous avons pu
identifier l'auteur de l'appel pas de
témoin personne nous dit avoir vu
physiquement une personne dans cette
cabine téléphonique ou avoir vu un
véhicule qui pourrait nous intéresser
une fois de plus c'est l'impasse
quant à la perquisition de l'appartement
d'étudiante d'Élisabeth Griffin elle ne
donne pas plus de résultats les
gendarmes ont bien trouvé un ADN non
identifié dans le studio mais pour
l'heure ils n'ont pas de suspect avec
qui le comparer l'enquête il faut bien
l'admettre tourne en rond puisque
toutes les prélèvements et examens qui
seront fait que ce soit dans la voiture
que ce soit sur les documents trouvés au
domicile d'Elizabeth rien ne permettra
la moindre identification
et ce qui va finalement faire redémarrer
l'enquête c'est un petit cahier trouvé
dans la voiture de la jeune femme
son agenda
[Musique]
à la gendarmerie de Notre-Dame de
Gravenchon qui centralise les recherches
l'agenda personnel et le carnet
d'adresses d'Elizabeth Griffin sont
décortiquées dans leur moindre détail
chaque ligne est analysée chaque numéro
de téléphone appelé et vérifier
et les enquêteurs vont avoir un coup de
chance extraordinaire parmi les dizaines
de noms qu'il rencontre il s'aperçoivent
qu'il y en a un qui revient souvent
celui de Jean-Yves Morel
[Musique]
ce nom lorsqu'il est prononcé évoque
immédiatement un souvenir pour la
gendarme Christine Allanic
et c'est à ce moment-là que moi présente
ce jour-là l'unité je fais la relation
avec la disparition de Marie-Hélène ou
monsieur Morel était également impliqué
entre guillemets puisque sa belle-sœur
avait disparu de chez lui coïncidence
surprenante Jean-Yves Morel le
beau-frère de Marylène dont on est sans
nouvelles depuis un an et trois mois
maintenant et donc une connaissance
d'Élisabeth Griffin disparue elle une
dizaine de jours plus tôt autre
coïncidence le lieu où l'on a retrouvé
la voiture d'Elizabeth Lillebonne se
trouve à moins de 5 km du village de La
Fresnais la même ou Marylène a été vue
pour la dernière fois elle disparaît
également dans cette espèce de triangle
un peu maudit de Normandie c'est-à-dire
entre Lillebonne Saint-Nicolas de La
Haye et la Frenay
et en plus les deux jeunes femmes se
ressemblent elles sont brunes toutes les
deux et elles ont une morphologie très
proche avec le rapprochement fait par
les gendarmes avec la disparition
antérieure de Marylène
il est clair que Jean-Yves Morel
apparaît comme le coupable idéal mais
rien ne vient corroborer ce qui n'est
qu'une hypothèse de travail
[Musique]
pour la cellule d'enquête il faut
d'urgence interroger Jean-Yves Morel
l'homme est immédiatement convoqué à la
gendarmerie
[Musique]
le 16 juillet 1997 Jean-Yves Morel se
présente devant les gendarmes de
Notre-Dame de Gravenchon
l'homme à 33 ans c'est un employé de
laboratoire sans histoire et il jouit
d'une réputation de bon père de famille
il semble bien difficile de l'imaginer
en criminel il rend service il est
aimable c'est quelqu'un qui va
régulièrement à la messe il a même un
profil de séminariste on a envie de dire
il est toujours bien bien propre sur lui
avec ses petites lunettes carrées
nous est présenté comme un personnage
très correct très sérieux apprécié de
tout le monde et même nous par rapport
au contact qu'on a avec lui
quelqu'un de très courtois de très
différent très posé et on difficile
d'imaginer Morel comme étant l'auteur
d'une agression quelconque
d'ailleurs Jean-Yves Morel coopère
volontiers avec les gendarmes il
reconnaît facilement que lui et
Elisabeth Griffin se connaissait
il nous explique qu'il a fait la
connaissance
d'Élisabeth
au mois de août
96 lors d'un stage effectué dans
l'entreprise où il travaille il continue
de se voir ils échangent des cours donc
rien d'extraordinaire à ce que ses
coordonnées soient trouvés dans le
véhicule ou dans les papiers d'Elizabeth
Griffin Jean-Yves Morel et Elisabeth
Griffin serait donc simplement des
étudiants qui se sont entrainés et sont
restés en contact le fait qu'il soit lié
aux deux jeunes femmes disparues
récemment dans la région ne serait que
pure coïncidence Jean-Yves Morel est
donc libéré
mais dans les jours qui suivent les
gendarmes découvrent que Jean-Yves Morel
ne possède pas d'alibi car le 24 juin
jour de la disparition d'Elisabeth
Griffin il était en congé de quoi
nourrir à nouveau leur soupçon on
poursuit nos investigations et on
demeure têtu ont été parce que on pense
néanmoins que cette hypothèse est quand
même une hypothèse très importante c'est
plus une sensibilité d'enquêteurs et
côté intuitif qui fait qu'on se
concentre et qu'on aborde jamais la
piste morale d'autant plus que c'est un
personnage qui se présente sous un
aspect très avantageux alors les
enquêteurs vont jouer leurs atout et
malgré l'absence de preuves matérielles
ils vont placer Jean-Yves Morel en garde
à vue
[Musique]
le 9 octobre 1997 les enquêteurs se
présentent au domicile de Jean-Yves
Morel à la Fresnaye et l'homme est
interpellé
les gendarmes comptent sur deux éléments
pour prouver sa culpabilité l'ADN
inconnu prélevé dans le studio
d'Elizabeth Griffin et le mot mystérieux
retrouvé dans sa voiture on va faire des
prélèvements d'ADN sur Monsieur Madame
Morel pour qu'on puisse prendre le temps
d'un garde à vue les faire
analyser et expertisé par les experts
ADN d'un côté et de l'autre côté enfin
des experts graphologiques
seulement lorsque les résultats des
expertises arrivent toutes les
hypothèses des gendarmes s'effondrent
en revanche la perquisition opérée au
domicile du suspect va fournir au
gendarmes de nouveaux éléments
dans le grenier dans un dans un grand
carton nous découvrons 140 cassettes à
caractère pornographiques on trouve des
kilos on dit des kilos parce qu'on
s'était au poids on était plus ou au
nombre de revues on trouve un nombre de
revues à caractère pornographique
important
rien dit illégal mais cette découverte
cadre mal avec l'image de Jean-Yves
Morel un bon père de famille connu pour
sa discrétion sa tranquillité et son
assiduité à la messe dominicale
on découvre ce jour-là un trait de
personnalité de Monsieur Morel qui nous
était jusqu'à lors inconnus la
perquisition se poursuit et une nouvelle
surprise
dans son bureau Jean-Yves Morel possède
quantité de documents concernant
Elizabeth Griffin la jeune femme
disparue en particulier des CV et des
photos
[Musique]
interroger sur ce point Jean-Yves Morel
se justifie ces documents lui auraient
été remis par Elisabeth elle-même en vue
d'une éventuelle en bouche
Morel évidemment continue de clamer son
innocence il l'avait eu comme stagiaire
et il était très proche d'elle mais
jamais il n'aurait eu le moindre
accrochage verbal ne serait-ce que le
moindre avec elle et il a il a pu la
revoir mais c'est simplement dans le
cadre d'un nouveau stage qu'elle
souhaitait effectuer à son entreprise
prochainement et alors que la garde à
vue dure déjà depuis de longues heures
tout à coup Jean-Yves Morel annonce
qu'il a une révélation à faire
il explique que peu de temps après la
disparition d'Elizabeth il l'a vu en
pleine ville bien vivante
après un temps de repos nous dit avoir
vu vivant Elizabeth Griffin le 27 juin à
Lillebonne en compagnie d'autres autour
de jeunes filles c'est un élément pour
le moins troublant et nouveau qui va
désarçonner les enquêteurs donc cela
nous a bien interrogé bien sûr mais pas
convaincu forcément d'autant plus que la
révélation de Jean-Yves Morel va
s'avérer complètement à vérifiable on va
dans la commune on vérifie tous les
commerces on recherche des témoins on en
trouve pas on essaie d'identifier des
jeunes filles on en trouve pas
Jean-Yves Morel aurait-il menti
pour les gendarmes les raisons de le
soupçonner sont décidément nombreuses
seulement ils ne disposent d'aucune
preuve tangible alors après 36 heures de
garde à vue la cellule d'enquête se voit
obligée de relâcher Jean-Yves Morel
l'affaire aurait pu en rester là mais va
bientôt connaître un incroyable
rebondissement
le 6 janvier 1998
le docteur Griffin le père d'Elizabeth
vient signaler à la gendarmerie avoir
reçu un étrange coup de téléphone
c'est quelqu'un qui ne se présente pas
un coup de fil anonyme et qui dit vous
devriez dire ça aux gendarmes
Jean-Yves Morel a fait des travaux
à la période même ou autre enfant a
disparu
qui est le mystérieux informateur jamais
on ne le saura
ce qui est certain c'est que quelques
semaines plus tard un journaliste va à
son tour recevoir un appel anonyme il
s'agit d'Eric l'aînée
et il s'était intéressé à la disparition
d'Elizabeth Griffin dans un article pour
son hebdomadaire le nouveau détective
c'est une voix d'homme qui est à l'autre
bout du fil un homme qui reste qui reste
anonyme et qui me dit voilà vous avez
traité de la disparition d'Elizabeth
Griffin et cette disparition n'est pas
la seule il y a une autre disparition
que vous pouviez mettre en lien avec
celle d'Elizabeth Delphine c'est une
autre jeune fille dont la disparition a
été classée en fugue il y aurait d'après
c'est un cette interlocuteur un point
commun entre ces deux disparitions un
homme un homme qui a effectué des
travaux de terrassement dans son jardin
le mystérieux informateur ne en dira pas
plus mais Eric Lainé va mener l'enquête
et il ne tarde pas à découvrir
qu'effectivement une autre jeune femme a
disparu Marylène Rousset n'est qu'un
homme fait le lien entre les deux
affaires Jean-Yves Morel le journaliste
décide alors de s'entretenir au
téléphone avec lui il est tendu je sens
tendu au téléphone mais il me dit qu'il
n'a rien à voir avec ses double
disparition d'abord qu'il continue à
chercher Marylène Rousset comme au
premier jour qu'il se sent responsable
de sa disparition parce qu'elle a
disparu à son domicile et qu'il fait
tout et que la famille reste soudée et
qu'ils font tout pour continuer à
chercher Marylène pour ton convaincu de
l'implication de Morel
Eric lainer rédige un article pour son
journal il y énumère les éléments
communs aux deux disparitions qui à
kidnappé Marylène et Elisabeth une série
de coïncidences désigne le suspect
numéro 1 si la première Marylène et la
belle-sœur de Jean-Yves aiment la
seconde Elisabeth ne lui est pas
inconnue non plus cette fois tous les
regards se tournent en direction de
Jean-Yves Morel
a commencé par celui des gendarmes
décembre 1997 les gendarmes décident de
s'intéresser de près à la maison de
Jean-Yves et Nadine Morel
le couple a acheté ce pavillon il y a 2
ans mais les enquêteurs ont découvert
que Jean-Yves Morel depuis y a fait de
nombreux aménagements
il a en particulier acheté du béton
beaucoup de béton au contact l'ancien
propriétaire de la maison pour savoir
dans quel état c'était à l'époque où ça
a été vendu et
nos investigations confirment que Morel
a construit une terrasse béton ou
d'autres sa maison terrasse à ses
conséquences
ou ils auraient pu faire disparaître
facilement le corps d'Elizabeth
Jean-Yves Morel aurait-il pu enterrer
les corps des disparus dans son jardin
les gendarmes décident d'en avoir le
cœur net
le 28 avril 1998 à 7h du matin une
équipe de la gendarmerie se présente au
domicile du suspect à la Fresnay
nous sommes reçus par lui-même qui
toujours très courtois après qu'on lui
explique le but de notre visite nous dit
textuellement faites votre travail
messieurs les enquêteurs ne sont pas
venus seuls
ils sont accompagnés de deux géologues
équipés d'un géoradar
une machine toute nouvelle capable de
détecter la moindre anomalie sous le sol
sans avoir à creuser
[Musique]
c'est une un engin qui était utilisé
pour la première fois dans la faire du
trou et qui va leur permettre
éventuellement de détecter des zones
suspectes à la recherche évidemment d'un
corps qui aurait pu être enfoui dans le
sous-sol du terrain de Jean-Yves Morel
le terrain est découpé en petits carrés
chaque parcelle est étudiée mais pendant
de longues heures le géoradar ne repère
rien de suspect
il est 4 heures de l'après-midi
lorsque les géologues repérant enfin une
anomalie non pas dans le jardin mais
dans le sous-sol du garage
[Musique]
ce sont quelques gendarmes qui avec des
simples pelles comment ça retirer la
terre
et au bout de quelques
heures de travail
pour avoir retiré environ 80 cm de terre
nous découvrons une partie bétonnée
[Musique]
de la interrogation morale qui est
présent
ne sait pas que correspond cette dalle
qui est complètement étranger que c'est
pas lui qui est à l'origine de
cette table c'est un sarcophage c'est à
dire que dans cette dalle de béton on a
un corps c'est l'idée première
persuader qu'il touche au but les
gendarmes commencent à attaquer la dalle
de béton au marteau-piqueur
on s’équipe de d'éclairage parce que la
nuit commence à tomber et on est dans un
bruit assourdissant entre les marteaux
de piqueurs qui tapent
vers 23h30 la dalle est entièrement
enlevée
[Musique]
et encore situation d'échec puisque sous
cette dalle ni rien que de la terre
battue vont tous se regarder en se
disant mais non c'est pas possible il y
a rien on fait on a vraiment fait fausse
route et on est avec Morel qui lui
pressera discute de choses et d'autres
de ses vacances
de sujets insignifiants il est tout à
fait à l'aise et très peu inquiet
mais en réalité Jean-Yves Morel n'a pas
du tout l'esprit tranquille et c'est
cela qui va le perdre
[Musique]
Jean-Yves Morel va passer à un coup de
téléphone depuis la maison à sa femme
Nadine pendant que les gendarmes
poursuivent les fouilles
seulement ce qui l'ignore c'est que
toutes ces conversations sont sur écoute
et l'échange qu'il va avoir avec son
épouse confirme aux enquêteurs que
l'homme a quelque chose à cacher
là il creuse on attend de savoir
[Musique]
on attend de savoir quoi dis-moi
non mais attends de leur décision quoi
oui mais tu attends savoir il y a
quelque chose là-dessous non non il y a
rien non et à cet instant ce que
Jean-Yves Morel va dire à sa femme va
interpeller les enquêteurs
bon ben pas de souci à te faire alors
non non de toute façon c'est trop tard
je peux rien leur dire après ça va être
encore pire
tu peux pas leur dire quoi
je vais raccrocher prends soin d'Hélène
au maximum et puis oh non
[Musique]
aussitôt je contacte les collègues sur
place en leur disant il faut vous
acharner il se passe quelque chose
Jean-Yves que je viens d'avoir en direct
c'est pas le même homme ce qu'on fait là
ça le dérange il y a quelque chose c'est
sûr il faut trouver
les gendarmes continuent donc de creuser
sous la dalle de béton les fouilles
durent maintenant depuis 7 heures le
trou a atteint un mètre 40 de profondeur
il est presque minuit quand soudain
étant dans le fond avec un collègue nous
voyons apparaître un morceau de
plastique noir
[Musique]
de là tout ce tout se fige parce que là
il se passe autre chose on a compris
qu'on était dans une autre situation et
que je pense que là tout le monde a eu
conscience qu'on arrivait
au butinal de l'enquête et tout le monde
se regarde
et on se demande s'il faut l'ouvrir ou
pas
et là je prends un objet tranchant un
coin de pêche je craque le plastique
[Musique]
et une odeur immonde envahie tout de
suite le garage
on ouvre et je vois une main apparaître
[Musique]
tout s'arrête le bruit on est dans
une situation tout à fait bizarre on
redoute et on voudrait mais on redoute
également parce que c'est
quelque part l'émotion prend le dessus
quoi ce corps à l'intérieur du sac de
plastique noir c'est celui d'une jeune
femme au poignet attachée à cet instant
Jean-Yves Morel comprenant qu'il est
démasqué s'éloigne à pas long du garage
une réaction réflexe pour essayer
d'échapper à la situation une réaction
de je pense pas que ce fuite mais il
veut échapper
et on le rattrape dehors on lui demande
qui sait c'est qui c'est qui nous dit
c'était Elisabeth
c'est bien le corps d'Elizabeth Griffin
qui se trouve dans ce sac de plastique
sous le garage son cadavre est quasiment
nu il ne porte qu'un soutien-gorge
en revanche pas de trace de la
belle-sœur de Jean-Yves Morel Marylène
je lui pose la question
et Marylène et il me dit Marylène ce
n'est pas moi
entre temps les pousses de Jean-Yves
Morel nadine est arrivé sur les lieux et
le commandant de la cellule d'enquête le
lieutenant Michel frottier lui annonce
la terrible découvertes
[Musique]
c'est je pense que c'est tout ce que
peut
ressentir de plus atroce une personne
elle le ressent elle découvre que son
mari et certainement un meurtrier elle
découvre qui a un corps qui cachait
chez elle et il y a eu découvre en même
temps qu'une HCC que de lui mentir
Jean-Yves Morel est mis en examen pour
le meurtre d'Elizabeth Griffin
pour les gendarmes un grand bon vient
d'être accomplis dans l'enquête mais il
leur reste encore une question à tirer
au clair Jean-Yves Morel a-t-il aussi
tué Marylène Rousset et si oui où se
trouve son corps
[Musique]
incarcéré à la maison d'arrêt de Rouen
Jean-Yves Morel fait une tentative de
suicide pendant le week-end des deux et
trois même 1998 mais il échoue le
lendemain il est extrait de sa cellule
pour un nouvel interrogatoire
épuisé psychologiquement l'homme cette
fois passe des aveux complets et il
explique que dans son jardin il y a un
deuxième cadavre il va être emmené par
les gendarmes sur son jardin et il va
désigner l'endroit
où est la dépouille de Marylène Roussel
il n'a fait aucune difficulté pour
indiquer de lui-même au gendarmes
l'endroit où il fallait creuser ce
deuxième corps vient d'être découvert
français qu'il s'agit du cadavre de
Mademoiselle roussette le corps reposait
à 30 cm de profondeur sous un arbuste
les gens Yves Morel ne variera pas dans
ses aveux qui est relatif au meurtre des
deux jeunes femmes par contre les
circonstances dans lesquelles il tuera
les deux jeunes femmes vont varier
les corps étant resté longtemps sous
terre l'autopsie des victimes est
particulièrement difficile à réaliser
mais une chose est certaine Elisabeth et
Marylène ont toutes les deux été tués de
façon extrêmement violente
le médecin légiste conclut que pour
Elisabeth Griffin le décès serait dû à
au moins cette coupe sur la tête tandis
que pour Marylène grossesse c'est un
couple violent sur la tête qui serait
responsable du décès
face à la violence des faits qui lui
sont reprochés Jean-Yves Morel donne des
versions très fluctuantes
d'entrée il s'écroule dans les mois de
mes enquêteurs il donne une version très
rapide en audition où il reconnaît être
l'auteur d'une agression
sur sur Marylène
et voici la version que donne Jean-Yves
Morel pour le meurtre de Marylène
le 5 avril 1996 Jean-Yves Morel serait
rentré chez lui il aurait trouvé
Marylène qui l'attendait assise sur le
canapé
à l'époque il prétend qu'elle est lui
aurait été amant depuis plusieurs mois
et ce jour-là la jeune femme aurait
menacé de le faire chanter
il avait une relation sexuelle consentie
avec sa belle-sœur et ce jour-là le jour
de la disparition de Marylène Rousset
elle aurait menacé de tout révéler s'il
ne lui remettait pas une somme de 3000
puis de 5000 francs d'après Jean-Yves
Morel Marylène avait même préparé ce
petit mot pour donner le change à sa
famille
mais comme il l'aurait refusé de céder à
son chantage sa belle-sœur se serait
emportée et l'origine Flée
ça déclenche en quelque sorte sa colère
[Musique]
enfin il la frappe
ça se passe mal et il veut la faire
taire et il la frappe et il lui porte
des coups à la tête même le sol
[Musique]
il explique qu'elle était
inanimé et que paniquant il l'a enterré
de suite on l'a déshabille
[Musique]
il précise que il venait de créer un
trou pour planter un arbre dans son
terrain et que il l'a déposé aussitôt
dans ce trou qui la recouvert
immédiatement
[Musique]
c'est ensuite que Jean-Yves Morel aurait
téléphoné à sa femme Nadine lui
racontant que Marylène avait quitté la
maison en ne laissant derrière elle que
ce petit mot
[Musique]
concernant le deuxième meurtre celui
d'Elisabeth Griffin
Jean-Yves Morel donne là encore une
explication qui met en avant une mort
accidentelle
le 24 juin 1990 sept il se trouvait chez
lui lorsque la jeune femme lui aurait
rendu visite
Elizabeth Griffin est venu à son
domicile ce jour-là elle est passée à
l'improviste et ils ont eu une dispute
qui portait sur le travail
Elisabeth aurait reproché à Jean-Yves de
ne pas être assez efficace pour lui
obtenir un job d'été
devant ses reproches l'homme aurait
perdu son sang-froid brusquement
accidentellement dit-il il a il s'est
énervé il ne sait plus contrôler il a il
a saisi d'Elizabeth Griffin et il lui a
fracassé la tête contre le carrelage de
la pièce à vivre
lorsqu'il a fallu se débarrasser du
corps il aurait cette fois pensé à la
cave qu'il avait commencé à creuser dans
son garage
de là lui est venu l'idée de mettre le
cordelisabeth dans ce trou il a utilisé
donc une une brouette il a déposé le
corps au fond de son trou qu'il a
recouvert de terre
et que par la suite il en fera recouvrir
quelques jours plus tard au début
juillet qu'il fera recouvrir de
vêtements cependant un détail ne colle
pas si ce que dit Jean-Yves Morel est
vrai comment expliquer que le corps
d'Elizabeth était retrouvé vétu
seulement d'un soutien-gorge
[Musique]
les enquêteurs ont de sérieux doutes
dans les deux cas Jean-Yves Morel se
donne presque un rôle de victimes poussé
à des meurtres accidentels par deux
femmes qu'il dépeint comme agressive les
gendarmes vont décider de poursuivre
l'interrogatoire ils vont lui poser
encore et encore les mêmes questions
la garde à vue va durer toute la nuit et
le lendemain matin Jean-Yves Morel ça
vous vaincu il donne une nouvelle
version des faits concernant le deuxième
meurtre celui d'Elizabeth Griffin
il reconnaît avoir téléphoné depuis la
cabine publique de la remue pour
confirmer le rendez-vous
d'Elizabeth dans la matinée Elisabeth
aurait accepté à accepter de venir
pour les gendarmes ce coup de téléphone
ressemble à un stratagème pour attirer
la jeune femme dans un piège mais
Jean-Yves Moret affirme qu'il a appelé
Elisabeth sans penser à mal vers 11h la
jeune femme s'était présentée chez lui
sans méfiance et contrairement à sa
première version Morel avoue cette fois
que sans raison il l'a agressé peu de
temps après son arrivée il l'a violée
donc ce qui explique que le corps est
retrouvé dénudé et comme elle menaçait
de tout dénoncer et qu'il voyait d'après
lui son couple s'effondrer il s'est
énervé il a perdu son sang-froid et il
l'a attrapé saisie et violemment il lui
a violemment projeté la tête contre le
carrelage à cette reprise
à propos de Marylène Morel ne change pas
sa version des faits ses aveux
concernant les deux affaires sont
désormais suffisants ils comparaîtra
devant les assises de Rouen sous les
qualifications d'homicides volontaires
précédé de violer de meurtre et son
procès va réserver quelques surprises
[Musique]
reconnaît les meurtres de sa belle-sœur
et d'une étudiante de 24 ans
le 16 février 2000 à Rouen le public se
presse à l'entrée du palais de justice
l'affaire Morel comme on l'appelle
maintenant passionne les foules
et tout le monde en fait
attend de voir Jean-Yves Morel
cet homme qui avait l'air si tranquille
à la fnaie et qui finalement est
responsable d'un double meurtre dans les
conditions étonnantes
c'est celui que vous croisez que vous
voyez tous les jours en pensant que
c'est un bon père de famille c'est ça
peut être celui qui a tué des gens qui
valaient tuer
il est symptomatique de du docteur jeky
et de Mr Hyde
entre temps Jean-Yves Morel est revenu
sur ses aveux de viol il s'en tient
maintenant à sa première version pour
Elisabeth comme pour Marylène il est
devenu meurtrier par accident sans
préméditation
mais c'est une thèse difficile à croire
pour l'avocat général Jean-Marie bonnet
étant donné la violence des mœurs
ça dure un certain temps les actes de
violence dans les deux cas
c'est pas une affaire où il y a un coup
qui est porté ou même un coup de feu ou
un coup de couteau
c'est c'est n'oublions pas que ce sont
des meurtres à Manu
[Musique]
donc il nécessite
une violence certaine de la part de
l'auteur
[Musique]
de plus durant les débats un élément
sordide va particulièrement choquer juré
et auditoire un élément qui jusque là
n'avait jamais été évoqué concernant les
conditions de la mort de Marylène
on est à l'audience on entend médecin
légiste le médecin légiste qui a fait
cette autopsie et qui sur les questions
va nous dire
cette jeune fille que dans le corps a
été découverte géotopier
vraisemblablement elle n'était pas morte
quand elle a été enterrée elle était
vivante sans doute inconsciente mais
vivante
[Musique]
évidemment sur le bon départ civils et
notamment au sein de la famille Rousset
la consternation est complète les froids
et total c'est trop c'est trop fort
Nadine Paris immédiatement de la place
qui est la sienne au milieu des parties
civils quittent la salle et il y a une
chape de plomb sur l'ensemble du public
à ça a été pleine tout le monde a été
écrasé par le poids de ce que l'on
venait de découvrir à cet instant
et même l'avocat de la défense mettre la
garde aura du mal à trouver des
arguments pour défendre son client je
plaide donc pour Morel en le présentant
comme il est présenté par tout le monde
y compris la presse c'est-à-dire un
monstre je plaide
essentiellement
qu'il
devrait mériter en quelque sorte une
part d'irresponsabilité
précisément en raison des ce qu'il a
vécu lorsqu'il était tout jeune enfant
cette enfance violente ce sont les deux
sœurs de Jean-Yves Morel qui viennent en
témoigner d'après elle leur père était
un homme particulièrement brutal qui
frappait le jeune Jean-Yves et se
montrer souvent cruel avec lui
il y a des scènes terribles qui sont à
la fois rapportées par Jean-Yves Morel
mais également par ses soeurs à la barre
de la cour d'assise il y a d'abord
ces exercices de mathématiques par
exemple que lui fait réviser son père au
domicile familial et à chaque fois que
Jean-Yves Morel échoue dans un dans un
exercice son père sort une une à une des
petites tortues d'eau de l'aquarium pour
les écraser avec un marteau
mais quel que soit le passé de Jean-Yves
Morel sa culpabilité et la gravité de
ces deux meurtres ne va plus longtemps
faire de doutes aux yeux des jurés
[Musique]
il est un peu plus de 20h hier soir à
Rouen le public sort dans le calme il
vient pourtant d’applaudir à tout rompre
le verdict la perpétuité contre
Jean-Yves Morel Jean-Yves Morel et
condamné à la prison à perpétuité
le père d'Elizabeth Griffin est le
premier à son féliciter la justice a
fait son œuvre
dans son honneur la peine est justifiée
mais pour la famille de Marylène Rousset
le procès laisse un goût d'inachevé
jusqu'au bout Jean-Yves Moret la soutenu
que sa belle-sœur était sa maîtresse et
voulait le faire chanter une thèse
insupportable pour la famille de la
victime
je pense que pour les
roussets
notion de perpétuité avec une mesure de
sûreté maximale c'était pas leur affaire
je crois réellement c'était pas leur
affaire je crois que ce qu'il voulait
c'était savoir comment les choses
s'étaient passées et surtout que
Marylène soit pas responsable ou
présentée comme responsable de ce qui
était arrivé c'est un soutenable mais
qui voulait bien plus que la peine parce
que finalement ça leur indiffère
comprendre ou entendre des choses qui
n'ont pas entendu
[Musique]
Jean-Yves Morel est incarcéré au centre
de détention de Caen il garde avec lui
une partie de ses secrets
[Musique]
le lieutenant frottier l'adjudant
vpierre eux partagent une même
conviction l'homme aurait été un tueur
en série
Marylène Rousset et Elisabeth Griffin
n'aurait été que les premières victimes
sur une liste qui aurait pu être plus
longue
il était qu'à ses débuts en allant de
temps il avait tué de jeunes filles
qu'il avait assassiné en sodomie tu es à
son domicile qu'il a enterré son
domicile et il cherchait à rencontrer
d'autres personnes sa qualité n'est pas
fini pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui qui
fait partie des tueurs en série
Jean-Yves Morel aurait-il été un serial
killer en puissance
personne ne le sait
à part peut-être lui-même
[Musique]